volver a poner en pie la unión europea
es el principal reto al que se enfrenta
emanuel macrón para ello el jefe de
estado que se prepara para asumir la
presidencia del bloque durante seis
meses quiere centrar su política en tres
palabras clave recuperación y poder y
pertenencias hay que decir que no faltan
proyectos el primero de ellos es sin
duda la pandemia de kobe 19 que ha
provocado una crisis sanitaria y
económica sin precedentes la cuestión de
las fronteras también debería ser
predominante en un momento en el que
muchos migrantes están llegando a las
puertas de polonia y en el que rusia
amenaza las fronteras de ucrania de
manuel macrón aboga por una unión
europea más autónoma militarmente ya
está prevista una cumbre sobre defensa
para marzo otros temas que francia
debería abordar son la reforma de los
acuerdos de schengen el paquete
climático con el impuesto sobre el
carbono o la reorganización de la
relación con áfrica desde su elección en
2017 el presidente francés no ha dejado
de posar como defensor de europa frente
a los nacionalismos y populismos que se
extienden sin embargo es probable que
estas prioridades se topen con
divisiones entre los 27 estados miembros
la presidencia francesa también se
considera una ventaja para manuel macro
no posible candidato a la reelección en
las elecciones presidenciales previstas
para el próximo abril pero también una
papeleta que complica su trabajo las
principales reuniones se han organizado
durante los tres primeros meses de la
presidencia francesa